bumble founder whitney wolfhard becomes
a younger self-base self-made woman
billionaire after ipo bumble founder
uh uh is now worth uh one and a half
billion dollars at 31 years old
she's also the youngest chief executive
to take a company public in america
female co-founded a company about seven
years ago in order to reinvent the
dating app structure the app
unlike its competitors gives women the
ability to control the conversation
it is the only dating app where women
make the first move however her journey
into the digital dating scene didn't
start with bumble
in fact prior to her start with the
multi-billion dollar company she
co-founded the biggest competitor
tinder wolf heard left hinder and filed
the lawsuit against the company alleging
sexual harassment tinder denied any
wrongdoing
and the suit was eventually settled
shortly after in 2014 she founded bumble
bumble also owns the dating app badou
together the apps are used in 150
countries with tens of millions of
monthly subscribers thoughts
it's so fascinating i mean she's a rock
star she's unbelievable to think that
she
helped create tinder and you think of
the perception of tinder is there a more
creepy
dating app out there clearly i'm not an
expert on dating apps but that just
seems to me
as being creepy it'd be like you started
penthouse and then you quit and then you
started national geographic i mean going
to what she did
with bumble but she's brilliant she's
worth 1.5 billion you know she sued them
on her way out and got a million dollars
because she was dating the four
the other co-founder of tinder and she
sued him for sexual harassment he
allegedly called her a [ __ ] and a gold
digger and things like that so she got
out
with vengeance she went out to create
their competition
and destroy them i mean that was
literally her philosophy and she did it
mission accomplished it's unbelievable i
learned about bumble through my barber
all right young guy probably at 26 good
looking dude he go hey
tz i'm i'm on bumble man it's
unbelievable what is that and he's
telling me about
he's pulling out his phone showing me
all the girls that make the first move
he had two serious relationships and i
think he might get engaged now
to the one that he's been dating she's
beautiful you got to get two of them no
no
he had a relationship that's impressive
i mean it's unbelievable he's going for
his third it's incredible is he armenian
he's just he loves women no uh no he's
found now he's found someone that i
think he's gonna get engaged to
so it's it's great you know if she had
done the spec
accelerated this even sooner could she
would she have to give up more equity
is that part of the downside for a
company or for a founder like that that
you're giving up more and you're
and do the employees get a little chunk
of it because here's the other thing
that she did over the weekend the new
york post
got a hold of a slack message from her
that she sent out to the whole staff
they went public last week they killed
it you know it went up like
i don't even know the numbers i haven't
written down but it exploded in the next
two days
she sent a slack message out to
everybody and say hey
don't look at the stock price don't
think about the stock price
i think that's an unfair thing to say to
employees because if you were there to
help create that company
that is your end game the the stock
options that you have
how can you not i mean you know that
you're going to make me make
a few million so i i think that was
disingenuous i thought that was a bad
move for her to do that
now the other stat i have and it's
really unbelievable
is they only have 70 if full-time
employees
to build a company of that value with 70
i mean that is i mean find me a man
that's done that that's incredible oh
i'll find you a man all right right on
bumble
um a couple different things i've a
never done a dating app in my life and
now do we have a lie detector in the
office
this is not good adam just listen god's
watching you right now
just tell the truth just tell the truth
okay guys match.com
the first like this the first app i've
ever used is bumble i just
recently started using it and the women
have to make the first move they're
pretty aggressive out there let me tell
you they're they're out there they so
have you been approached
oh sorry what happened what happened
tell us i haven't opened the app in a
few uh
in a few minutes oh my gosh 700
messages he hasn't been able to open it
like 12 full-time jobs
what's the approach what's been the best
approach ladies will
will message you and say like things
like
hey sweetie hey handsome i saw your
profile hey buddy you know not hey buddy
but
you know for him it's just sweet and
handsome
yeah just whatever they're they're but
they do make the first move so then you
obviously
you uh okay oh what's up girl you know
that i was like what's your address i'm
coming i'm on my way
that's tinder that's tinder i've never
done tinder but i might have to look
into that soon
um no for all the funny guys out there
never done grinder but
hey listen if you've got enough money
what's up he keeps bringing up the apps
he hasn't done i think that's saying
something
but um something uh someone pointed this
out i would love to give
whitney wolf heard credit
you know youngest female billionaire
like obviously everything that's going
on i would love to give her credit for
that
you pointed out well kylie jenner
actually was the youngest
self-made billionaire but she didn't go
public but then you find out whitney
wolf heard
who's who's heard who's that guy
who's her husband well it turns out
michael heard is like an
oil tycoon and from texas our old
stomping grounds
and believe me he had some
positive influence in the in the
framework of this company so it wasn't
like
some you know lowly girl started a
dating app and made it
like to the big leagues she had a
billionaire buddy husband that you know
that i don't know if she met him on a
dating app or not but
then how old is her husband do you know
is he a lot older
no okay similar adam also she started
the company in 2014 and they didn't get
married till 17. i mean they might have
met
before but it seems like what are your
shots listen are you like
are you trying to get a free bumble
account what are you trying to do make
me look bad just state the truth what's
your what's your fault
honestly what's my profile yeah i'm
bumble like what do you mean what is the
name on buzzer just kylo if they wanted
to find you
really they can't they can't search it
though the norwegian style
why how do you so you can't search the
name on bumble no it's
it's based off location oh okay so you
have to be location okay
i'm soy boy everywhere all three uh 50
states i'm everywhere
just find me ladies on the soyboy mafia
channel is there anything else to say
about this or that's
bumble one thing i was waiting like it
changed my life no it
has not changed my life yet yet one
thing i will say i've
i've done my due diligence you know i'm
literally ocd methodical i say
you know i i asked a couple of my dating
gurus who were you in high school what's
up what's up and
without a doubt everyone's like hinge
and bumble that's where you got to go
hinge and bumble that's where it's
hinged hinge h-i-n-g-e
not a good name for a dating side really
hinged hinged
no it's not hinged why what hinge
bro take my car if you need to okay
but kai has kai have you not met a girl
on bumble
no actually not what that what are you
doing so you know your speaker's off
yeah
kai what app do you because you've done
you've done some you've done some more
i've used more hinge
okay there it is got it well if you're
looking for a hot norwegian man ladies
hinge up kai loot it first of all good
for her that's all i can say
good for her for you know doing what she
did tinder and the
change one little thing you were talking
about girl approaches
you approaching them you know changes a
little bit and uh got a market for it
where it's a little bit more where the
guy's there and if you're approachable
then they'll approach you and you have a
you know somewhere to take an extra you
know what let
let's pull up bubble right now let's see
what we got
can you imagine you read a message and
you make fun of the girl and ends up
becoming your wife one day i would love
that story here we go we got bumble here
it is
it's yellow yellow for like a bumble bee
he's a premium member by the way who is
this
what's up who's this who's this wow so
what you do is you say all right what's
this girl's name all right that would go
to the right you matched
she she had already requested me she had
already requested me there it is
all right keep swiping i don't know see
this is a
two girls in the picture which one of my
two girls in the same picture
i'm telling you that's not bumble listen
you're not on bumble i'm on bumble
that's
gr
[Laughter]
pandemic this girl put a picture of like
her hot friend with her dating's just a
whole different world
turns out it's not so you got to go left
on that one this girl's got a far-off
bikini pic
you got to get closer that's an oddity
guys for you yeah
the point is there's there's a lot of
dudes we got to finish this podcast so
you can go message all
right for the next hour you need an
assistant to manage that whole thing pat
we've been talking about that what's
crazy is i
i i was never around single during the
app era
yeah yeah so i have no clue but
i have plenty of people around me who
are using the greek god
uh that would have been the name greek
god
your birthday's october sort of ten ten
sixteen
eighteen ten eight close yeah greek god
1018 message pbd
okay so listen if uh if you're on bumble
i guess this was uh
the advertisement for uh adam today's uh
message is a sponsor these podcasts are
sponsored by adam sosnick's
bumble account you can find them in boca
raton adam
sosnick soyboy he is single
and uh he's looking very good with
finances healthy works out where it's
very short shorts and
uh athletic i don't know what else to
say knows how to do different accents
he's funny he's comedic yeah he can do a
jewish
accent he can do german russian i mean
extremely talented thank you i
appreciate extremely talented so that
was an outdoor
right there there it is put that on my
bumbo profile
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye